Salut, moi c'est Guillaume Hachez. Bienvenue dans Septante Minutes Avec. Pour ce deuxième épisode de Septante Minutes Avec, deux invités.
On passera d'abord une heure avec Laure Lemaire, la directrice de Interface3.
Interface3, c'est une école d'informatique réservée aux filles qui compte plus d'élèves qu'il n'y a d'étudiants en informatique dans toutes les universités belges francophones réunies.
Et juste après ça, une interview de trente minutes avec Isabelle Collet, qui est maîtresse de recherche en sciences de l'éducation à l'Université de Genève.
Let's go ! Et bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour un nouvel épisode de ce podcast. On est ici aujourd'hui avec Laure Lemaire.
Laure Lemaire, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Vous êtes la directrice de Interface3, un centre de formation en informatique exclusivement pour les femmes. Est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter pour ceux qui ne vous connaissent pas ?
OK. Donc moi, je suis directrice d'Interface3 depuis dix ans. Donc, je représente là, pour l'occasion, l'équipe. Mais donc, c'est bien toute une équipe qui construit le projet.
Si vous voulez un peu me connaître, je peux dire que je suis sociologue de formation et économiste et que j'ai d'abord travaillé dans la recherche
sur tout ce qui est justement impact des nouvelles technologies sur les transformations du travail, des compétences, des qualifications nécessaires et des besoins en formation
avec la Fondation Travail Université pendant des années.
Et puis j'avais envie de faire quelque chose qui soit plus un travail de terrain. Et comme j'avais rencontré Interface3 via des études que je faisais, des recherches que je menais, finalement, je me suis--
voilà, j'ai commencé à travailler chez Interface3 comme chargée de projet.
Et puis le poste de direction s'est libéré et j'ai tenté l'aventure et je suis toujours là dix ans plus tard.
OK, super. Interface3, ça a démarré au début des années 90, fin des années 80, c'est ça ?
C'est ça, exactement. Au milieu des années 80. Donc, Interface3, c'est un projet monté par des femmes qui travaillaient plutôt au niveau de la recherche sur le marché du travail en Europe
et qui voulaient faire quelque chose de concret pour favoriser l'égalité des hommes et des femmes sur le marché du travail.
Alors, on sait bien qu'il y a,
qu'il y a un peu différents types d'inégalités sur le marché du travail, dont des inégalités de salaire,
qui sont dues aussi à ce qu'on appelle la ségrégation horizontale sur le marché du travail, qui est le fait que finalement, les métiers sont quand même assez sexués.
Et donc il existe des métiers non mixtes. Donc, il y a les métiers qui sont essentiellement occupés par les hommes.
C'est beaucoup de métiers techniques, entre autres. Et puis, de l'autre côté, on a les métiers qui sont plus réservés aux femmes.
Et là, on a tout ce qui est soins aux personnes, éducation. Et finalement, on reproduit assez bien les tâches traditionnelles des femmes à la maison.
Parce que même s'il y a des femmes docteurs, des femmes avocates, etc. Statistiquement, quand même, ça fait depuis l'après-guerre, donc depuis les années 60, ça ne bouge pas beaucoup.
Les femmes sont surreprésentées dans le secteur qu'on appelle du care, donc soins aux personnes, éducation, etc. Donc, Interface3 a choisi cet angle d'attaque bien précis.
Donc l'idée, c'était d'aider les femmes à s'insérer sur le marché du travail dans des secteurs porteurs. Alors porteurs, ça veut dire en termes de salaire, de conditions de travail, d'opportunités de carrière,
mais aussi de statut social, parce qu'il n'y a rien à faire, il y a des métiers qui posent mieux en société que d'autres.
Et donc c'était le début de la société de l'information au milieu des années 80. Et donc Interface3 a décidé d'essayer d'aider les femmes à s'adapter à la société de l'information qui émergeait.
Et donc petit à petit, les formations sont nées. Au début, c'était une formation, puis deux formations. Aujourd'hui, il y en a onze.
Formations longues, donc qualifiantes, qui mènent à l'emploi avec un stage en entreprise. Et donc on a suivi l'évolution de l'IT.
Donc notre cible au départ, c'était vraiment que les femmes s'emparent de la société de l'information, qu'elles soient actrices plutôt que spectatrices.
Parce que le problème auquel on est confronté, mais toujours aujourd'hui, même si ça fait une trentaine d'années que nous, on travaille là-dessus, le problème est toujours d'actualité.
Bien sûr.
C'est que les femmes sont des usagers des nouvelles technologies, ça, c'est sûr. Elles tchatent, elles surfent sur Internet, etc.
Mais elles ne développent pas les applications qui sont derrière.
Mh. Mh.
Et elles ne s'occupent pas non plus de l'infrastructure. Et donc quelque part, ça veut dire que la moitié de l'humanité n'est pas représentée dans la façon dont l'informatique est aujourd'hui développée.
Donc, il y a quand même un enjeu de société important. Je veux dire, d'un côté, il y a le fait que c'est dommage que les femmes ne s'emparent pas de métiers aussi passionnants et aussi porteurs.
C'est-à-dire, il y a beaucoup d'emplois dans l'IT et des emplois qui ne sont pas pourvus par manque de main-d'œuvre qualifiée.
Donc ça, c'est dommage que les femmes n'en profitent pas. Et d'un autre côté, pour la société, c'est dommage que les femmes ne fassent pas partie des développeurs en général.
Donc, ce qu'on a trouvé comme formule un peu originale chez Interface3 pour favoriser les femmes dans les métiers de l'informatique, c'est de leur réserver nos formations.
En fait, ça nous permet de travailler sur les freins invisibles qui font que les femmes ne se dirigent pas vers ce secteur.
D'abord, il y a les stéréotypes qui assignent les gens, les genres, oui, à certaines vocations, on va dire.
Ça, c'est ce qu'on appelle les stéréotypes. Et c'est vrai qu'au niveau de l'orientation professionnelle, je pense que ça a un rôle assez important, surtout que
les jeunes, l'orientation, ça commence à l'adolescence et c'est particulièrement une période où on est très sensible à ce qu'on pense de nous.
Et donc, voilà, on s'éloigne difficilement du groupe. On va dire, c'est difficile d'être un outsider. Par exemple, pour un garçon, de dire : « Mais moi, je veux absolument être puériculteur. » Bon.
Vous avez un total de onze formations, vous me disiez, c'est ça ?
Oui.
Ça fait un total de, je crois, cent cinquante élèves par an, c'est juste ?
Un peu plus, cent soixante-cinq.
Cent soixante-cinq, d'accord. Pour une formation qui dure un an, c'est ça ?
Si ça ne vous dérange pas, je vais terminer sur les freins parce que c'est vraiment important pour comprendre la démarche. Parce que donc, il y a la question du stéréotype et puis le fait que
finalement, quand le PC personnel est arrivé dans les maisons, il a été, on va dire, un peu pris en main par les garçons et les hommes en général.
Et puis il y a la figure du geek qui est apparue.
Au cinéma, Hollywood.
Oui, un peu. Le garçon un peu asocial, boutonneux, etc. Ben ça ne le fait pas trop. Une fille a du mal à s'identifier à cette figure.
Du coup, ça les a éloignées de l'informaticien, je pense. Donc ça, c'est un premier constat. Mais le deuxième constat, c'est que en fait, il faut voir qu'il y a peu de femmes qui s'inscrivent dans les filières informatiques.
Donc, vous disiez moins de sept pour cent de femmes dans les masters, les baccalauréats, etc., en Belgique.
Dans les études supérieures.
Dans les études supérieures. Mais il y a quand même plus de femmes, si on regarde les professionnelles de l'informatique, je pense qu'on est autour de seize pour cent.
Et donc ça veut dire qu'il y a des femmes qui se réorientent vers l'informatique. Et ça, c'est notre créneau, justement.
C'est que les femmes qui viennent ici, c'est des femmes qui se réorientent vers l'informatique après avoir fait un autre choix en formation initiale.
Et là apparaît un deuxième problème qui est de nouveau un frein invisible, c'est que comme elles n'ont pas été encouragées jeunes à s'emparer de cette matière, elles n'ont en général aucun prérequis.
Par rapport aux garçons, il y a un handicap. Si vous voulez, il y aura plus de garçons qui auront déjà bidouillé avec le code, etc.
et qui auront déjà été, en autodidacte, chercher des tutoriels sur Internet, etc.
Moins de filles. Et donc si vous passez des sélections en formation professionnelle, parce que donc nous, on organise des formations professionnelles, ça veut dire qu'il y a quand même une sélection à l'entrée puisqu'on fait des groupes de quinze.
Donc, je ne sais pas, il y a soixante personnes qui se présentent pour une formation web application développeur, il faut sélectionner.
Et alors là, dans les formations professionnelles classiques, je ne vais pas nommer les opérateurs, mais un peu partout en Wallonie et à Bruxelles, en général, on demande : « Est-ce que vous avez une formation en code ?
» On demande : « Est-ce que vous avez déjà codé ? » Là, les garçons, ils ont une longueur d'avance, donc les filles ne passent pas la sélection.
Donc c'est pour ça que nous, on fait des formations non mixtes. Ça nous permet de ne demander aucun prérequis.
Donc on reprend tout à la base et on ne met pas en concurrence les filles et les garçons dans la mesure où les filles ont quelque part une sorte de retard technologique à rattraper.
Évidemment, je grossis le trait, hein, mais je veux dire, là, je parle de la majorité des personnes. Il y a toujours des exceptions.
Ça veut dire, il y a des filles qui sont geeks avant d'arriver ici, mais disons qu'elles sont de plus en plus nombreuses, mais elles sont quand même pas nombreuses.
Et donc c'est pour lutter contre ces deux freins invisibles que c'est efficace de faire des formations non mixtes, parce que d'une part, on peut les convaincre que c'est pour elles, leur montrer des rôles modèles,
leur permettre d'expérimenter la technologie.
C'est ce qu'on fait. Il y a des modules d'orientation avant les formations qualifiantes où elles peuvent se tester, c'est-à-dire voir si elles ont une affinité, des affinités avec le code ou avec le réseau, etc.
Donc ça, c'est pour lutter contre les stéréotypes. Et puis on commence au départ, on ne les met pas en concurrence avec les garçons et elles peuvent devenir le geek du groupe.
C'est ce qu'elles disent toujours. Elles ont dit que s'il y avait trois garçons qui s'y connaissent mieux dans un groupe de douze, je ne sais pas, ils vont dire par exemple : « Attends, je vois bien que t'as du mal, je vais t'aider.
» Et finalement, si on fait ça, on renvoie toujours les femmes à leur--
En besoin d'assistance et en besoin d'aide.
À leur soi-disant non affinité avec la technique.
C'est ça.
Voilà. Maintenant, si vous voulez, je reviens à toutes nos formations.
Mais j'ai envie de revenir à ce qu'on disait il y a un instant, le fait que
finalement, il y avait ici la fonction de ces formations en informatique était également un rôle d'ascension sociale dans la société, le fait de les former dans les métiers qui sont plus valorisés, mieux payés, etc.
moi-même, j'étais étudiant en sciences informatiques à l'ULB et le profil que je voyais arriver dans les auditoires, c'était, comme vous disiez, le profil, le cliché du geek
passionné qui a vraiment l'informatique dans le sang, dans son identité.
J'ai l'impression que vous me dites que les élèves qui viennent ici à Interface3 n'ont pas forcément ça, entre guillemets, dans le sang ou dans leur identité, mais viennent avant tout dans un besoin d'ascension sociale, dans un besoin de,
oui, de meilleures conditions de vie, d'un meilleur rang, entre guillemets, dans la société. C'est juste ?
C'est vrai qu'il y a une motivation qui est que c'est un secteur qui est pourvoyeur d'emplois. Et ça, à partir d'un certain âge, tout le monde l'a compris.
Parce qu'on a souvent des femmes qui ont déjà travaillé, donc qui ont constaté dans leur environnement de travail que l'informatique était omniprésent.
Ça peut être une dame qui travaille, par exemple, à l'accueil du Sheraton, qui vient de commencer une formation de web application développeur.
Elle, c'est dans son travail qu'elle a constaté que l'IT était important. Et puis après, il y a les connaissances, les gens qui l'entourent, qui lui en ont parlé, etc.
Donc, elle est venue
pour ça. Donc essentiellement d'abord pour trouver un boulot.
Mais en fait, il y a aussi beaucoup de femmes qui, ayant déjà travaillé, alors ça peut être dans la communication, parce qu'on a, par exemple, des personnes qui ont travaillé dans la communication, on a, je ne sais pas moi, des ex-caméramans, on a
des personnes qui ont travaillé,
ben histoire de l'art.
Enfin, on a un peu toutes sortes de profils. On a aussi des profils moins qualifiés au départ qui arrivent ici, mais toutes, elles se sont rendu compte que l'IT pouvait les amener plus loin.
Et alors, il y en a pas mal aussi qui viennent pour le côté créatif de l'informatique. Elles ont envie de créer des choses.
Par exemple, je pense à une comptable, une jeune femme qui avait fait des études de compta et qui trouvait que ce n'était pas assez créatif, son métier.
Et voilà, elle avait envie-- l'informatique, ça lui plaisait.
Donc c'est souvent des personnes qui ont découvert l'informatique dans leur
environnement de travail, dans leur premier environnement de travail et qui se sont rendu compte qu'avec ça, peut-être, elles vont faire des choses plus intéressantes, plus chouettes.
Et puis après, il y a celles à qui on renvoie toujours le fait que ça leur manque. Je ne sais pas moi, les graphistes, les journalistes.
À un moment donné, ils sont confrontés plus vite aussi au fait que s'ils savaient programmer ou s'occuper du web en général, ils se débrouilleraient mieux.
Donc voilà. Et de temps en temps, on a quand même quelques geekettes qui-- surtout pour les jeux vidéo.
Ah oui.
Là, on a fait une découverte en ouvrant une nouvelle formation développeuse de jeux vidéo, que-- enfin, ce n'est pas une découverte.
Il y a beaucoup de filles qui jouent aux jeux vidéo, mais qu'elles ont vraiment ça dans le sang et qu'elles ont envie de s'en emparer. Voilà, ça, c'est--
C'est un point très intéressant. C'est que finalement, je reviens à l'auditoire, le fameux auditoire de sciences informatiques à l'ULB où il y avait peut-être quatre filles sur cent personnes, c'est que
le chemin que ces cent étudiants ont suivi pour arriver dans cette filière, ils n'ont pas été sensibilisés à l'informatique via des cours qu'ils ont reçus au sein de l'enseignement obligatoire en secondaire ou quoi.
C'est une passion qu'ils se sont découverte dans leur temps libre, chez eux, en jouant aux jeux vidéo, à Pokémon, à League of Legends, etc.
En passant beaucoup de temps sur leur PC, etc. Effectivement, c'est une porte d'accès qui est genrée, des jeux vidéo faits par les garçons, pour les garçons, pensés avec les garçons en tête.
Et donc oui, ce n'est pas une surprise de voir que les quelques filles qui sont joueuses, ce n'est pas une surprise de voir qu'elles sont vraiment passionnées et qu'elles ont le côté, la geekitude dans le sang.
Ça, c'est... J'ai envie de revenir juste sur le rapport. Vous publiez un rapport annuel sur Interface3, un long PDF de cinquante pages chaque année.
J'étais surpris de voir que les profils des étudiants, enfin des élèves qui viennent à Interface3 sont très marqués.
On voit qu'il y a plus de la moitié qui sont issus de l'immigration. On voit qu'il y a une tendance de,
elles sont très peu nombreuses à venir de Woluwe-Saint-Pierre et elles sont bien plus nombreuses à venir de Molenbeek, de Schaerbeek, etc.
Comment expliquer cette tendance ?
Bon, il faut savoir qu'au départ, on est un organisme d'insertion socio-professionnelle et donc, au démarrage, Interface3 travaillait uniquement avec un public qui n'a pas terminé l'enseignement secondaire.
C'est de cette façon-là qu'on a un agrément avec la Cocof, en étant organisme d'insertion socio-professionnelle.
Et donc ça oriente déjà le public avec lequel on travaille. Donc au départ, on travaillait qu'avec des personnes qui n'avaient pas achevé l'enseignement secondaire.
Et forcément, ces personnes-là, vous les trouvez davantage dans les quartiers que vous avez cités et dans les populations avec une origine migratoire ou les primo-arrivants, parce qu'il y a aussi des diplômes non reconnus là-dedans.
Donc, vous voyez, c'est notre public de départ, on va dire. Après, comme on a décidé de continuer à faire évoluer nos formations avec l'évolution de l'informatique,
on a été obligé de glisser un peu,
pour ce qui est des métiers IT purs, donc la programmation, je ne sais pas, full stack développeur, front-end développeur, administratrice système et réseau, vers des profils un peu plus qualifiés au départ.
Parce qu'on s'est rendu compte qu'en une année, s'il faut apprendre de la programmation, donc devenir quand même assez bon dans quelques langages de programmation, si on n'a pas terminé le secondaire, ben ce n'est pas évident.
Parce qu'il y a une capacité logique, une capacité d'apprentissage qui doit être davantage travaillée avec les personnes qui n'ont pas terminé le secondaire.
Et comme les formats des formations qui sont quelque part imposés par les financements, une année, c'est déjà assez long.
C'est douze mois, c'est quand même des grosses formations. C'est trente-cinq heures semaine, donc c'est beaucoup d'heures.
On frise les mille quatre cents heures, hein, pour les formations au développement.
Et ben ça ne le fait pas. En tout cas, si on prend le public en masse, c'est-à-dire qu'un groupe avec des personnes qui n'ont pas terminé le secondaire, on a essayé, on n'y arrive pas. C'est trop dur.
Vous en accueillez encore.
On en accueille encore, il y en a dans les formations. Mais donc ces formations-là, elles ont glissé vers un public qui a déjà terminé son secondaire supérieur, voire qui a un diplôme du supérieur dans un secteur un peu bouché
et qui veut se réorienter.
Et évidemment, de temps en temps, il y a des personnes qui n'ont pas terminé le secondaire et qui se débrouillent très bien, mais c'est l'exception qui confirme la règle.
Donc, en fait, maintenant, on a deux publics et donc on a deux types de formations. On a les formations vraiment IT et on a aussi des formations,
à des profils plus administratifs et commerciaux, mais dans lesquels il y a beaucoup de bureautique.
Donc l'informatique est très présente, mais là, plutôt en tant que super usager.
C'est ça, en tant qu'outil.
Voilà, mais plutôt qu'en tant que
personne qui développe les applications. Et maintenant, on a aussi des formations à d'autres métiers techniques en collaboration avec Bruxelles Formation, parce qu'on s'est dit,
finalement, c'est une expertise d'arriver à convaincre les femmes de venir vers des métiers masculins, entre guillemets, donc on va élargir.
Et donc maintenant, on fait un profil électricien industriel avec Bruxelles Formation et magasinière.
Ah oui, donc là, pour vous, c'est vraiment de la diversification.
Oui, oui, tout à fait, oui. Mais toujours un peu avec la même logique, parce que c'est toujours les mêmes freins.
En gros, bon, c'est peut-être pire pour l'électricien industriel. C'est-à-dire, ça paraît encore plus éloigné pour les femmes, donc c'est assez difficile de recruter d'ailleurs et de convaincre les femmes.
Et pourtant, ça marche très bien. On a fait trois éditions et elles sont toutes engagées par Veolia, qui s'est beaucoup impliquée dans le projet.
mais on travaille toujours sur ces fameux freins invisibles, c'est-à-dire les filles qui voudraient
se réorienter après le secondaire et après une première expérience professionnelle, qui voudraient se réorienter vers l'électricité, ben elles vont de nouveau arriver sans,
avec zéro prérequis, alors que les garçons qui vont se présenter,
ils auront souvent fait électricien résidentiel dans le secondaire, en professionnel, là où il y a zéro fille.
Et donc ils ont une longueur d'avance. Donc nous, ben, on fait la même chose, on fait une préformation, on redonne les bases, on donne confiance, on fait des rappels en mathématiques, etc.
Donc on fait de la manipulation d'outils, manipuler la foreuse, la scie à métaux, etc. pour qu'elles puissent ensuite entrer en formation qualifiante chez Bruxelles Formation.
Vous faites une sélection à l'entrée, justement, pour choisir les élèves qui sont capables de suivre le cursus ?
Alors, oui, il y a une sélection. Elle est basée surtout sur des tests de logique et sur un entretien de motivation.
Parce que les formations professionnelles, c'est un peu comme si vous étiez au travail. C'est trente-cinq heures semaine, vous devez être présent parce que vous continuez à toucher vos allocations de chômage quand vous avez la chance d'en avoir,
mais à condition que vous soyez là.
Donc c'est pas comme à l'unif ou quoi, on va, on vient. Si on n'est pas là, c'est pas grave. Non, c'est un peu différent.
Donc il faut quand même être très motivé. Et puis il faut être motivé pour entrer dans ce secteur-là. Et alors, le test de logique, lui, sert un peu justement à évaluer la capacité à apprendre.
Et surtout, il est assez révélateur à ce qui va se passer quand vous allez aborder la programmation informatique.
C'est-à-dire, après dix ans d'usage de ce test, on voit assez bien, en fonction du niveau de réussite du test, c'est plus ou moins facile pour vous, la programmation.
Voilà, donc pour nous, c'est un indicateur. Si vous vous plantez carrément, ça va être dur. Mais on s'arrête pas là.
On donne la possibilité d'expérimenter pendant quatre semaines la programmation ou le réseau ou... Enfin oui, de toute façon, on a un peu deux types de formation.
Il y en a où il y a beaucoup de programmation et puis les autres, c'est de l'infrastructure. Et donc, elles ont l'occasion de vraiment se tester et nous, on a l'occasion de les tester aussi.
Et là, on prend un groupe plus large que le groupe final.
Voilà. Et puis on offre aussi des modules d'orientation et des modules d'initiation tout à fait en dehors des formations qualifiantes qui permettent aux femmes de découvrir les métiers et de tester leur affinité avec.
Je pense que vous menez également des actions au sein des écoles secondaires.
Oui.
Qu'est-ce que vous leur dites exactement à ces jeunes filles ?
Alors, pendant tout un temps, on a mené un projet qui s'appelle Informaticienne d'un jour. On le fait plus depuis quelques années.
Et là, donc, on animait un atelier sur les stéréotypes dans le monde informatique avec les jeunes.
Donc là, c'était des groupes mixtes. Forcément, c'est les classes. Donc on leur faisait réfléchir un peu à la figure de l'informaticien, c'est qui, c'est quoi, il fait quoi.
Puis on déconstruisait un peu les stéréotypes avec eux. On leur présentait un peu la richesse du métier. Et puis, on les emmenait en entreprise une demi-journée.
Et donc là, ben, ce qu'on leur dit aux filles, c'est : « Vous pouvez tout à fait y aller, c'est aussi pour vous, c'est passionnant.
Et puis c'est pas juste coder toute la journée devant son ordi, c'est avoir des relations avec des clients, c'est analyser un projet, c'est construire des applications, avoir des idées.
» Donc voilà. Et puis aujourd'hui, on anime un projet qui s'appelle Girls Day Boys Day et qui est initié par la Communauté française.
Non, je devrais dire la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles. Et euh-
Même sur le site internet, parfois, ils se trompent.
Ils buguent. Et donc là, l'idée, c'est de montrer aux garçons et aux filles qu'il y a des métiers non mixtes et de réfléchir avec eux pourquoi.
Mais donc ce projet-là, c'est pour encourager autant les filles d'aller dans les métiers techniques que les garçons d'aller dans des métiers qui sont étiquetés féminins comme infirmier, instituteur, assistant social.
Et donc là, ils rencontrent des témoins qui travaillent dans des métiers qui sont pas normalement pour leur sexe, entre guillemets.
Ça peut être une femme pilote d'avion, une femme mécanicienne, une femme informaticienne, un homme sage-femme, voilà.
Mais pour approfondir un petit peu cette question-là-
Oui.
On le disait tout à l'heure, seulement 7,2 % des étudiants en sciences informatiques ou en ICT dans les études supérieures sont des femmes.
C'est le ratio le plus mauvais de tous les pays de l'OCDE. En tant qu'experte de la question, entre guillemets, comment est-ce que vous expliqueriez ça ?
Mais je pense que vous avez vous-même identifié, enfin, reformulé un peu ce que je dis et ce que d'autres disent sans doute, c'est que la porte d'entrée aux études informatiques est assez genrée, hein, puisqu'on a dit-
C'est le cas partout dans le monde.
Oui, d'accord, mais bon, on va commencer parce qu'on se connaît.
Oui.
Puis après, se poser la question sur la Belgique. Donc ça, c'est déjà une bonne explication pour ce qui est du peu de femmes qui entrent en formation initiale en informatique.
Pourquoi c'est pire en Belgique ? Alors là, ça, je...
Pas la moindre idée.
Non, parce que nous, on s'occupe moins-- enfin bon, oui, on s'occupe moins de la problématique de l'entrée en formation initiale puisque nous, on est un peu l'école de la seconde chance.
Donc on a plus des femmes qui se réorientent. Donc la problématique est un peu différente.
mais ce que je constate, c'est que, ben enfin, je viens de vous le dire, les femmes, elles s'orientent souvent vers l'IT parce qu'elles ont compris l'utilité de l'informatique dans un autre domaine.
C'est-à-dire, elles ont travaillé dans un domaine où elles ont réalisé que l'informatique était omniprésente et pouvait peut-être être une voie intéressante pour elles.
Donc il faut que ça ait du sens pour elles. Alors, il y a la question, voilà-- il y a la-- pour les femmes, je pense, peut-être plus jeunes, il y a la question du sens.
Qu'est-ce que je vais bien pouvoir faire avec ça ? Évidemment, si on leur montre pas, ça n'ira pas. Sinon, pourquoi-- parce que c'est pire en Belgique, mais est-ce que les écarts sont énormes ?
Parce qu'en France, c'est quoi ? C'est-- peut-être, on fait pas assez de campagnes, peut-être il y a pas assez d'IT dans-- Bon, c'est sûr, un des gros problèmes, c'est qu'il y a pas de vraie informatique à l'école secondaire, on est bien d'accord.
Il y a des cours de bureautique, mais ça, c'est pas-
Oui.
C'est pas de ce problème-là dont on parle, c'est de vraiment faire des filles et des garçons, des développeurs d'applications, des-- enfin des gens qui maîtrisent la sécurité, l'infrastructure, la programmation.
Et donc la solution, ce serait en effet d'introduire des cours qui présentent un peu toutes les facettes de l'informatique en secondaire.
Il y a le côté créatif aussi qui est attirant.
Mh. Je vais peut-être proposer une hypothèse et vous allez me dire si vous pensez que je fais complètement fausse route.
Quand on observe les pays comme le Maroc, l'Algérie, l'Arabie Saoudite, là, on observe des ratios autour de 50/50 pour Polytech, pour l'informatique, etc.
Et ce sont des pays où les problématiques sont plus, en sociologie, on dit matérialistes, dans le sens où la clé du problème, c'est mettre du pain sur la table, ramener de l'argent à la maison pour des problèmes très concrets.
Là où, entre guillemets, les pays où la situation économique est plus aisée, on va avoir des individus qui vont chercher à s'orienter sur base de leur identité, sur base de ce qui leur correspond, qui ils sont.
Et dans des sociétés qui sont ultra genrées, on se définit avant tout sur base de son sexe, son genre. Et je sais qu'en Belgique, on est le pays avec le-- c'est le pays où on a le plus d'argent par individu en moyenne.
On a un excellent-- on a un PIB par individu très élevé. On est relativement aisé en Belgique, relativement.
Est-ce qu'il n'y aurait pas-- est-ce que vous pensez que je vais dans le bon sens ou est-ce que ça vous paraît un peu capilotracteur ?
Non, non, c'est intéressant ce que vous dites. Évidemment, moi, je pensais qu'on parlait de l'Europe. Alors
en Europe, on va dire, allez, bon il y a des PIB-- enfin, je veux dire, il y a des niveaux de vie différents, évidemment, si on prend le Portugal ou la Belgique, la Finlande.
Mais c'est vrai que vous avez raison, quand on va voir ailleurs, c'est très différent. En Malaisie, c'est exactement l'inverse, par exemple.
Je veux dire, je crois qu'il y a 60 % de femmes dans les facultés d'informatique. Donc, et là, probablement que le métier est présenté comme particulièrement féminin parce que il peut--
je veux dire, vous êtes plus en retrait, vous êtes derrière votre écran, c'est propre comme métier. Donc
je sais pas si parfois-- enfin, il y a ce que vous dites, je suis d'accord avec vous, la question de l'orientation professionnelle, elle est probablement très différente dans des métiers où,
enfin pardon, dans des pays où le niveau de vie est moins important et la motivation des jeunes, c'est d'abord un métier où il y a du boulot et qui va rapporter.
Donc ça, je vous suis. Maintenant, c'est contradictoire en même temps, si on regarde le Maroc ou l'Algérie, etc., où les femmes sont aussi quand même assez encouragées à rester à la maison.
Donc voilà, ça vient presque-- c'est pas que ça contredit tout à fait ce que vous dites, mais enfin quand même, ça pose un petit problème.
Et en Malaisie, là, je sais pas trop-
C'est encore plus visible en Arabie Saoudite où elles sont euh-
Oui, là.
46 % des étudiants en informatique sont des femmes et seulement 6 % des travailleurs en informatique sont des femmes, justement à cause des raisons-
Et là, je me demande si y a pas aussi des stéréotypes dans l'autre sens qui rentrent,
qui sont favorables à l'IT alors, parce que je vous dis, en Malaisie, ben j'ai pas bien étudié la question, mais je sais que
des arguments qui sont avancés, c'est que c'est un métier qui peut être fait-- enfin, développeur, oui, vous pouvez travailler en partie à la maison quand même, même si c'est du travail d'équipe et la plupart sont en entreprise.
C'est propre aussi comme métier. Donc vous êtes quand même un peu souvent un travailleur de l'ombre. Alors vous êtes pas, vous voyez, vous êtes pas en relation avec le public directement, etc.
Donc dans les métiers où on encourage pas les femmes à justement se montrer et être, voilà, face au public et tout, peut-être que l'informatique, ça paraît comme un métier convenable.
Voilà, bon ça, c'est une hypothèse qui est peut-être complètement farfelue, mais bon, puisqu'on réfléchit.
Voilà.
Non, c'est pas facile. Bon, tout le monde parle toujours des rôles modèles. C'est vrai que ça, ça joue hein. Évidemment, y a pas de, allez, de femmes dans l'IT qui sont encore très célèbres comme Mark Zuckerberg peut l'être,
ou d'autres, hein, Bill Gates, etc.
Ou d'autres encore qui sont même plus sexy pour les garçons. Y a pas ça, en effet, pour les jeunes filles.
Donc ça, ça aide pas, sans doute. Et puis bon, moi, je pense que les-- peut-être que la conception aussi des études universitaires ou des baccalauréats devrait peut-être être réinterrogée.
Est-ce que l'informatique, est-ce que ça serait pas plus judicieux qu'il y ait de l'informatique dans différentes disciplines ?
Hein, vous voyez, par exemple, oui, de manière plus transversale, par exemple, qu'on apprenne la programmation en économie, parce qu'après tout, enfin, je veux dire,
les entreprises sont bien contentes quand un informaticien connaît bien le côté business.
Mais ça pourrait être vrai pour la biologie, parce qu'aujourd'hui, la bioinformatique, ça pourrait être vrai pour probablement d'autres disciplines.
Donc, puisque si nous, on arrive à faire des développeurs juniors en une année, peut-être que dans un cursus universitaire de cinq ans, y a moyen, vous voyez, de faire des profils mixtes.
Et à ce moment-là, on aura plus de femmes et peut-être même
plus d'hommes, parce que j'ai pas bien suivi les inscriptions en informatique ces dernières années, mais je sais qu'y a même pas assez de garçons pour, je veux dire, pour la quantité d'emplois qui sont-
Ce qui est frappant également, c'est que les sciences informatiques telles qu'on les propose ici en Belgique, c'est vraiment très, entre guillemets,
faculté des sciences, blouse blanche, on va avoir des cours de statistiques, de bioinformatique, de mathématiques discrètes, de...
voilà. Y a pas de stage à la fin du master. Alors que quand on compare aux computer science aux États-Unis, on va avoir des cours sur le web, sur iOS, sur l'intelligence artificielle.
Ils ont un stage à la fin du cursus, à la fin de leur master. Donc, on a vraiment des orientations très différentes et je pense qu'on perçoit encore l'informatique comme étant une science dure et vraiment
pas du tout comme étant quelque chose de fonctionnel et de transversal, en tout cas au sein de l'université.
On a grosso modo quatre grandes façons de se former en informatique en Belgique. Il y a l'université. Ensuite, il y a toujours l'enseignement supérieur.
On a les hautes écoles qui sont déjà un peu plus concrètes avec des parcours de type plus court en trois ans. On peut être autodidacte.
Et puis, il y a finalement les instituts de formation tels que le vôtre. Et on a effectivement l'impression que les publics sont complètement différents en fonction de la voie dont il est question.
Et on voit effectivement beaucoup plus d'individus qui sont issus de quartiers moins favorisés, qui sont en reconversion, qui sont peut-être plus âgés.
Et j'étais très surpris de voir que quand j'ai demandé les chiffres au Forem et à Bruxelles Formation, de voir que
dans cette dernière catégorie, donc les instituts de formation dont il est question, on voit 33 % de femmes contre 7 % dans les études supérieures.
je pense que finalement, c'est aussi parce que le public est différent et parce que les, comment dire,
les attentes, les critères du choix d'orientation sont complètement différents en fonction du public dont on discute.
Oui. Oui. 33 %, oui. C'est entre autres grâce à Interface3.
Ah oui.
D'ailleurs.
Si on enlevait Interface3-
Puisqu'on en forme 100 chaque année. Oui, parce qu'il y a quand même pas beaucoup chez Bruxelles Formation, par exemple,
il y a une ou deux filles de temps en temps dans un groupe de douze, treize, quatorze, mais les chiffres sont pas, voilà, c'est pas une moyenne, hein,
le 33 %, on va dire, en fonction des centres quoi.
Hum, hum. Hum, hum.
Donc oui.
C'est pas vrai partout, c'est ça que vous voulez dire.
Oui, voilà, oui, oui, c'est ça. Donc ça reste quand même-
Si on enlevait Interface3 de la moyenne, vous pensez qu'on tomberait à-
À Bruxelles, je pense bien, oui. Oui, oui, je pense bien.
À combien ?
Ben j'en sais rien. Il faudrait essayer. Il faudrait demander à Bruxelles Formation. Je ne sais pas. Je ne connais pas les autres chiffres, mais je sais qu'il y a peu de filles en général,
mais pour les raisons que je vous ai expliquées.
Mais vous avez raison, le public est très différent et vous avez entièrement raison de dire que les études informatiques, donc dans l'enseignement classique supérieur, sont perçues comme rébarbatives.
Entre autres, elles sont probablement un peu éliminatoires avec les maths. Et ça, mais je sais pas, mais pour former des développeurs, il y a pas besoin d'être champion en maths hein.
Donc c'est vrai que la formation professionnelle échappe à ce problème-là et donc ça encourage les personnes à devenir, oui, c'est ça, à se lancer.
Parce que je pense qu'il y a-- les mathématiques, ça, c'est quand même très désolant, mais ça reste une matière-- parce que nous, on travaille quand même avec beaucoup de personnes qui ont subi des échecs scolaires.
Et donc ça reste une matière qui est effrayante pour beaucoup de gens. Et surtout, il y a beaucoup de personnes qui arrivent ici et qui sont persuadées qu'ils sont très mauvais en maths.
Et c'est par exemple les électriciennes industrielles. Il y a des maths dans la formation, parce que pour l'électricité, c'est important.
Et on a des personnes qui se braquent et qui abandonnent juste à cause des maths donc.
Est-ce que le modèle d'Interface3 de faire un centre de formation non mixte, est-ce que ça a fait des imitateurs ?
Est-ce que certains ont tenté de reproduire l'expérience ?
Non, il y a assez peu de formations. Enfin, il y a assez peu de centres qui utilisent cette formule non mixte. Il y a des centres pour femmes
qui font d'autres, qui visent d'autres métiers, qui organisent des groupes non mixtes pour d'autres raisons aussi.
Ça, je peux vous expliquer aussi pour nos formations Païti, pourquoi c'est resté non mixte. Mais par contre, avec Bruxelles Formation, on s'est rendu compte que,
mais que c'était une façon vraiment de lutter contre la non-mixité et en tout cas au minimum pour rattraper le retard dans la technologie en question qui fait que les femmes n'arrivent jamais à rentrer.
Donc c'est comme ça qu'on a fait électricienne industrielle et magasinière, aussi pour mettre les femmes en confiance et qu'elles osent passer le pas en fait.
Parce que ce qui est difficile aussi, c'est d'arriver dans un groupe où il y a que des garçons. Mais donc il y a assez peu de-- non, il y a peu de centres qui
copient la formule parce que
je ne sais pas si vous, vous ouvrez un centre
pour aider les jeunes à se lancer dans l'IT parce que vous avez vu que c'était un domaine très porteur, que ça soit pour les start-up ou pour être engagé comme développeur, par exemple Modern Geek.
L'objectif initial est très différent. Interface3 a été créé pour aider les femmes à s'épanouir sur le marché de l'emploi.
Et comme l'informatique était incontournable, c'est pour ça qu'on est dans l'informatique. Mais c'est pas notre but premier de former tous les demandeurs d'emploi à l'IT.
Donc, vous voyez, donc notre ADN est différent. Donc, je comprends que, je sais pas, BeCode ou Modern Geek ne vont pas ouvrir des formations non mixtes.
Ils font leur possible pour avoir le plus possible de femmes. Et puis, bah, ça marche plus ou moins bien en fonction des années.
Ils ont 40 % de femmes cette année sur la coding school actuelle.
Oui, elle me l'a dit. Julie Volon m'a expliqué. Mais voilà, donc c'est pas-- ça dépend en fait de l'attention qu'on va prêter, je pense.
Je veux dire, les-- probablement que des groupes mixtes peuvent fonctionner si vous faites attention au moment du recrutement, de ne pas décourager les filles, etc.
Ça dépend un peu comment vous-- mais par exemple, regardez l'École 19 qui vient d'ouvrir. Je pense qu'il y a une, enfin, j'ai vu une fille, en tout cas, il y en avait peut-être deux.
C'est sans doute la directrice, la directrice pédagogique.
Non, non, non. Non, non, non. Ils ont engagé une fille parce que je l'ai vue récemment, elle a témoigné, mais-
Ah oui, d'accord.
Donc ils viennent de faire leur grande sélection dans leur piscine et je ne sais plus combien, 38 ou-
C'est frappant comment sur la photo, tous les élèves ont exactement la même tête, la même coiffure, les mêmes lunettes. C'est-
Oui, on est d'accord. Donc-
Très amusant.
Donc, je sais pas. Disons qu'il y a une première sélection de 40. Je pense qu'en tout cas, il y avait-- la fille qui a témoigné a dit que donc ils étaient 100 au départ ou 98, je ne sais plus.
Il y avait trois filles. Donc elle, en tout cas, c'est sûr, elle est prise. Les autres, je ne sais pas. Mais voilà, ça, c'est le reflet de la situation.
Et je pense que dès que vous faites jouer le-- on sous-estime parfois le manque de confiance que les femmes peuvent avoir dans leurs compétences professionnelles.
Déjà, les femmes sont moins éduquées à avoir confiance en elles, elles sont plus réservées. Et si en plus, vous attaquez un domaine qui n'est pas le vôtre et qui est réputé ne pas être féminin, c'est encore plus dur.
Donc, je crois qu'on sous-estime. On peut avoir des filles au début et puis si on leur demande trop de,
voilà, je sais pas, il y a des systèmes, par exemple, qui vous sélectionnent pendant un mois, vous vous débrouillez et puis vous devez réaliser des choses tout seul.
Faut déjà être costaud quoi. Alors, il y a toujours des femmes costauds, mais c'est pas la majorité. Donc, vous allez toujours avoir des petits nombres, en fait, en gros.
L'exemple de l'École 19 ou de l'École 42 est intéressant puisque justement, il y a quelques mois, dans la presse, on avait entendu parler de scandales, de comportements douteux au sein de l'École 42.
Je ne sais pas si vous aviez entendu parler.
Non, j'ai pas entendu.
Il était question de harcèlement, il était question d'un channel Slack où des photomontages douteux circulaient.
Vous proposez ici une nouvelle porte d'entrée au monde et à l'industrie informatique. Est-ce qu'une fois qu'elles sont rentrées dans ce secteur, est-ce qu'elles ne font pas face à un sexisme assez répugnant qui vont finalement
vite les encourager à changer de voie ?
Alors, je pense qu'elles sont assez malignes pour choisir, pour bien choisir leur entreprise aussi. Je veux dire l'entreprise où elles sont engagées.
Parce que ce que vous dites, c'est vrai, ça existe. Il y a d'ailleurs un très bon film qui a été fait par une Américaine qui est assez-- attends, je pourrais vous donner après les coordonnées de ce film.
Je me souviens plus du titre comme ça. C'est ce que vous dites, c'est-à-dire le harcèlement, les comportements très, très sexistes en entreprise, c'est assez vrai dans les entreprises qui se veulent,
allez, branchées, on va dire, pour faire simple.
Google et compagnie, enfin, je veux dire les grosses boîtes très créatives où vraiment, on cherche la figure du geek. 'fin de ce que j'ai vu dans ce film, en tout cas, il me semble que cette culture est plus présente là.
Maintenant, si vous êtes en Belgique, que vous allez travailler à la STIB, ils ont un département développement, hein, parce qu'ils ont pas mal d'applications, ils ont un site web, etc.
Ben ça, ça n'arrive pas. Si vous allez travailler dans une petite boîte, une petite start-up comme ATrust, par exemple, les femmes sont bienvenues et elles sont très bien traitées.
On a pas mal de développeuses qui ont été engagées par l'entreprise Smart, qui développe aussi pas mal d'applications.
Ça se passe très bien. Donc, je-- c'est pas-- ça, c'est peut-être plus vrai dans les boîtes vraiment identifiées IT, vous voyez ?
Mmh. D'accord.
C'est moins vrai-- 'fin, et je parle des grosses boîtes. Alors, à mon avis, c'est moins vrai dans les start-up et c'est moins vrai dans les entreprises qui ont un département IT.
Donc la culture d'entreprise n'est pas informatique de A à Z. Donc, je pense qu'elles échappent comme ça à-- donc on a très peu de retours dans ce sens.
Alors c'est vrai qu'il y a des femmes qui abandonnent, et on le sait hein, qu'il y a un taux de drop out du secteur de la part de la gent féminine.
Donc c'est pas gagné. C'est pas parce que nous, on les a formées, en effet, que la bataille est gagnée. Elles peuvent en ressortir.
Mais des échos que nous, on a, donc on forme une centaine de femmes à l'informatique chaque année, on a très peu d'échos de ce genre.
Peut-être un ou deux tous les deux ans, on va dire.
C'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle.
Oui.
Et est-ce que des start-up ressortent de Interface3 ? Est-ce qu'il y a une culture de-- culture entrepreneuriale, des gens qui ont vraiment envie de lancer leur projet ?
Est-ce que ça arrive ici, à Interface3 ?
Alors, c'est la minorité parce qu'on a affaire à beaucoup de femmes qui ont déjà des responsabilités, des enfants. Alors, pas toutes hein.
L'âge des stagiaires ici, ça va de dix-huit à cinquante-cinq ans, mais disons que la moyenne se situe plutôt entre trente et quarante. Et donc,
il faut qu'elles trouvent un boulot, pour faire rentrer de l'argent. Donc, elles vont plutôt--
elles vont pas-- elles vont avoir tendance à pas trop prendre de risques dans un premier temps et plutôt commencer avec un emploi de salarié, aussi pour asseoir leurs compétences informatiques, ce que je trouve quand même judicieux.
Parce que se lancer dans une start-up parce qu'on a juste fait une école, et voilà, c'est pas si évident. Je veux dire, parfois, il y en a besoin de se tester, d'apprendre encore sur le terrain.
Donc, on a assez peu ce type de profil et c'est vrai qu'au départ, comme elles sont en recherche aussi de sécurité, et là, je parle globalement de l'ensemble de notre public parce qu'on a vraiment des profils très diversifiés,
on n'a jamais poussé ce côté-là.
Maintenant qu'à Bruxelles, on agite beaucoup le, comment dire, la création de start-up et qu'on encourage, qu'on sensibilise, ça commence.
Nous, on les encourage à participer à des hackathons, on en organise nous-mêmes. Et le hackathon, il flirte avec la start-up tout le temps.
C'est pas juste du code, c'est aussi des idées et tout. Donc, ça commence à rentrer dans la culture ici, tout doucement.
Et on essaie d'encourager celles qui ont des projets à au moins continuer à les développer en parallèle ou-- et si elles ont envie, 'fin, on leur dit qu'il existe 1819, etc.
Et des tas de services qui peuvent les aider. Mais pour le moment, je dirais, ça concerne peut-être 10 % des personnes en formation chez nous. Oui.
C'est pas rien non plus hein, ça fait seize personnes par an, c'est ça ?
Ouais, non, là, c'est un peu exagéré. Une petite dizaine, on va dire. À peine.
D'accord. Oui, mais donc la culture d'entreprendre, également le faible ratio des femmes parmi les informaticiens en Belgique, ce sont les deux problèmes pour lesquels la Belgique est dernière de la classe.
Ce sont deux sujets qui me passionnent.
Si vous étiez responsable de la Belgique pour une semaine et que vous deviez résoudre ces deux problèmes et améliorer grandement, peut-être pas atteindre cinquante cinquante, mais améliorer grandement le ratio hommes-femmes
des métiers informatiques et des études supérieures informatiques, quelle serait la première étape, d'après vous ?
La première étape, c'est que j'impose dans les écoles, en primaire et en secondaire, des cours d'informatique dignes de ce nom, où on apprend vraiment à développer, où on montre tous les aspects, le côté créatif, mais aussi la sécurité, les réseaux.
Je pense qu'il y a vraiment-- alors, il y a aussi la question de l'apprentissage de la-- une gestion critique des technologies et une gestion environnementale.
'fin, pour moi, il y a beaucoup d'enjeux. Une gestion critique de l'analyse de l'information, mais ça, c'est un autre domaine.
On va dire que ça ressort plus des cours de, je sais pas, de citoyenneté ou de français, j'en sais rien, mais donc la première chose que je ferais, c'est ça.
Évidemment, ça passe par
la création aussi de nouveaux types d'enseignants. Je veux dire, il faut former les enseignants, donc il faut former
des filières peut-être probablement spécialisées, pour que les enseignants soient vraiment formés à l'informatique de façon pertinente.
Et puis, il y a au-- ben il y a toute une réflexion à mener sur à quoi pourraient ressembler ces cours hein, ça, c'est sûr.
Donc, et puis, il y a la question du matériel, mais ça, c'est le moins problématique, à mon avis. Ça, ce serait la première chose, je crois, que je ferais.
Et évidemment, je m'assurerais que les enseignants en question, il y a une parité quoi, moitié femmes, moitié hommes, parce que sinon, on va toujours retomber hein.
Et je donnerai des cours formation en genre aussi à ces enseignants. C'est déjà un vaste programme.
Mais donc, on a de la part de l'industrie, de la part du secteur, vraiment ces convictions qui sont portées, comme quoi il faut absolument rajouter des cours de programmation au sein de l'enseignement obligatoire.
Il y a actuellement, en tout cas du côté francophone et aussi du côté néerlandophone en fait, des réformes qui sont menées au sujet de l'enseignement obligatoire.
Mais finalement, la question de l'informatique, de la programmation est relativement absente. On parle dans certains rapports au mieux de mener quelques ateliers d'algorithmique en secondaire ou autre.
Comment est-ce que vous expliquez que le monde de l'enseignement, que ce soit le staff ou du côté ministériel, soit aussi peu réceptif à cette demande de rajouter des cours d'informatique dans l'enseignement obligatoire ?
Comment est-ce que-- Comment expliquer que ce ne soit pas une évidence pour tout le monde ?
Honnêtement, j'ai moi-même du mal à comprendre. Est-ce que c'est un problème budgétaire ? Est-ce que c'est un problème de réticence du corps professoral ?
Je comprends pas.
On a du mal à comprendre, non. Est-ce que c'est un problème de formation ? Non, c'est difficile à comprendre. Maintenant, est-ce que tout ce monde-là réalise pas assez, pas suffisamment ce qui se passe sur le marché de l'emploi ?
Ce qui se passe dans les entreprises, les enjeux des développements futurs et actuels au niveau technologique.
Mmm-hmm.
Je, j'ai du mal à m'expliquer.
Du mal comprendre.
Mais je reste, euh... Je veux pas foncer dans la critique facile parce que je sais à quel point c'est difficile de gérer, euh...
Nous, on travaille avec les pouvoirs publics et on est au cœur de tout ce qui est contraintes financières, etc.
Donc, voilà, je suis d'abord en empathie et puis j'aimerais bien qu'on m'explique.
Donc, quand j'avais évoqué cette question-là avec--
dans un épisode précédent, avec le vice-premier ministre et ministre de l'agenda numérique, Alexander De Croo, il expliquait qu'il y avait effectivement une certaine inertie dans le corps professoral, une certaine...
Voilà, que finalement, le milieu de l'enseignement n'avait pas tellement évolué en trente ans, ce qui est assez triste.
Et finalement, sa stratégie en réponse à ça, c'est peut-être fonctionner en dehors des écoles et de-- grâce à son, euh-
Digital Skills
...Digital Skills Punt, voilà, de proposer des Molengeek, des BeCode, etc., en dehors de l'enseignement obligatoire, avec à terme l'idée de se dire : « Mais
si ça fonctionne bien et que ça a du succès et que ça plaît, peut-être que les écoles finiront par s'y intéresser.
» Est-ce que vous croyez à cette stratégie-là ?
Non, je trouve que ça n'est pas une bonne idée. Je pense que pour qu'on soit sûr que ce monde soit à la portée de toutes et tous et que l'accessibilité prenne en compte des questions d'inégalité qui existent dans la société-
Ces formations sont gratuites.
Oui, mais attendez, je vais développer. Donc, je pense la meilleure façon, c'est de le mettre dans l'enseignement obligatoire.
Ça, c'est certain, parce que là, c'est sûr-
C'était son avis également
...tout le monde y passe. Alors maintenant, c'est vrai qu'à propos de l'inertie du corps professoral, évidemment, la première chose qui doit changer, c'est la formation des profs.
Et donc c'est là qu'il faut investir. Alors, est-ce qu'il y a assez de budget dans l'éducation supérieure ? Est-ce qu'il y a des budgets pour ça ?
Ça, c'est du ressort des politiques aussi. Donc, ça, c'est leur responsabilité et pour moi, c'est une responsabilité lourde.
Et il faut quand même dire que l'enseignement, euh... Bon, enfin, moi, je trouve pas du tout normal qu'il y ait autant de personnes qui sortent sans avoir terminé le secondaire à Bruxelles, donc qui sortent de l'école
sans avoir terminé leur diplôme, enfin, sans avoir un diplôme de l'enseignement secondaire supérieur, parce qu'aujourd'hui, ça devient vraiment le b.a.-ba, quoi.
Sans ça, je veux dire, au niveau salarial, vous êtes bloqué toute votre vie. Enfin bon, bref. Donc, moi, là-dessus, je suis assez fâchée, on va dire, avec le politique.
Et alors, OK, des initiatives comme BeCode et Molengeek, mais
je suis désolée, même si ces initiatives se présentent comme ouvertes à toutes et à tous, dans les faits, il y a quand même une sélection, il y a rien à faire. C'est,
c'est inhérent aussi à, comment dire, à la formule, c'est-à-dire à partir du moment... Enfin, en tout cas, nous,
ils s'approchent de la formation professionnelle, ils ont des conventions avec les courses de formation, même s'ils sont pas encore exactement dans le même carcan que nous.
Mais vous avez des groupes pas trop grands, parce que c'est comme ça que ça fonctionne, ces formations-là. Ça va jusqu'à vingt-cinq, on va dire, chez BeCode, mais il y a beaucoup de candidats.
Donc, il y a une première partie qui est assez sélective où on vous dit, voilà, de réaliser telle, telle, telle chose en grande autonomie, sans beaucoup d'aide.
Et il y a beaucoup de personnes qui n'ont pas assez de confiance en elles pour faire ça, que ça peut être des filles comme des garçons, ça dépend de leur background.
Et en plus, dans les nouvelles initiatives qui arrivent aujourd'hui, on a tendance à raccourcir les durées parce que pour les politiques, c'est mieux, c'est moins cher, à mettre moins de profs.
Il y a des coachs, vous allez vous débrouiller. Après tout, c'est une histoire d'autodidacte, l'IT. Enfin, je veux dire, pour moi, c'est un peu les clichés qu'il y a là-derrière et puis des raisons budgétaires. Et donc
nous, on a quand même en tout cas vingt ans d'expérience dans la formation à la programmation et on a réalisé quand même qu'une année avec des personnes qui ont déjà le secondaire ou déjà un diplôme du supérieur,
c'est tout juste pour arriver, c'est bien, on va dire, pour arriver au seuil d'entrée que les employeurs exigent pour un développeur junior.
On a testé, retesté, ça fait des années. Chaque année, ici, c'est cent stages. Je veux dire, les entreprises, on en a vu une diversité incroyable.
Donc c'est basé sur des constats très pragmatiques, ce que je vous dis. Et donc, on a tendance pour le moment à penser que le code va sauver le monde et à brader un peu, euh...
Enfin, moi, j'ai peur, en tout cas. En bradant les formations, vous vous adressez plus qu'à ceux qui, de toute façon, se débrouillent, vont se débrouiller très bien.
Alors, l'École 19, ça, c'est vraiment se débrouiller tout seul. Alors après, il y a dégradation. Mais donc non, pour moi, c'est une approche libérale de la problématique.
Et moi, personnellement, j'ai un problème avec ça, même si dans ces nouvelles initiatives, il y a des choses intéressantes à prendre.
Enfin, je veux dire, chaque nouvel acteur amène une pédagogie différente, une autre approche. Donc chacun a ses qualités, mais je pense que c'est très important d'avoir l'honnêteté
de, voilà, de bien se situer pour tout le monde, pour ceux qui vont rentrer en formation chez vous
et aussi par rapport aux politiques, de bien situer, c'est-à-dire analyser bien le public qu'on a, celui qui réussit
Moi, je vous cache pas que les formations de développeurs, c'est pas,
je vous l'ai dit, c'est pas des personnes qui n'ont pas achevé leur secondaire en majorité.
C'est des personnes qui ont déjà un bon niveau, elles ont déjà des compétences, donc elles ont des doubles compétences. Donc elles sont très attractives pour les employeurs.
Ça peut être une comptable qui est devenue développeuse, ça peut être une graphiste qui est devenue développeuse, ça peut être une journaliste qui est devenue développeuse.
Donc, je veux dire, le seuil d'entrée est élevé quand même. Donc il faut pas... Voilà, moi, ça me fait un peu peur, ce genre d'initiative.
Et donc, je reste persuadée qu'il faut vraiment populariser la programmation en la faisant passer par l'école. Voilà.
C'était, je pense, également sa conviction que l'école est un égalisateur universel, voilà, et c'est ce dont on a besoin, mais je pense qu'il agissait avant tout en réponse à une certaine inertie, à une certaine...
Finalement, c'est un ministre fédéral qui n'a pas de pouvoir sur l'enseignement. C'est un autre problème.
Oui, oui, non, mais ça, je comprends bien que Alexander De Croo, lui, il est effectivement hors-jeu pour ce qui est de l'enseignement obligatoire.
C'est régional, non, c'est communautaire, pardon. Et donc c'est là que se situe la manette. Après, il y a la question de comment on répartit les budgets dans un pays, sur quel poste on les met.
Mais bon, voilà, vaste, vaste sujet.
Une dernière question. Interface 3, c'est gratuit à l'inscription ? C'est financé par quelle manière exactement ?
Alors, donc en effet, les formations sont gratuites et elles sont financées par différents pouvoirs publics. Donc Actiris, pour ces formations, et le Fonds social européen en grande quantité.
Le Fonds social européen, je veux dire, ça représente une grosse partie de notre budget. Et puis aussi les salaires subsidiés de la Région bruxelloise, les ACS.
Et puis on travaille aussi avec les fonds sectoriels de formation, donc les cotisations des entreprises privées hein, qui sont rassemblées dans des fonds.
Et puis des sponsors privés, la fondation JP Morgan, la fondation Roi Baudouin, et puis des sponsors plus petits de la part des entreprises pour des choses, Microsoft, pour les certifications IT.
Donc voilà, on a une quinzaine de financeurs différents, je pense.
Qu'est-ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter pour les années à venir ? Est-ce que Interface 3 a pour ambition de s'élargir encore ou bien est-ce que vous continuez sur cette lancée actuelle avec cent soixante-trois étudiants par an ?
Donc il faut savoir qu'on forme quand même presque plutôt trois cents étudiants par an, parce qu'on a aussi des modules d'orientation, des modules d'initiation en plus des formations qualifiantes.
Et donc qu'est-ce qu'on peut nous souhaiter ?
D'abord, un taux d'emploi toujours meilleur pour les stagiaires. Actuellement, le taux d'emploi moyen chez Interface 3, si on prend toutes les formations, tous niveaux confondus, ça tourne autour de septante-cinq pour cent.
Pour les formations IT en développement, ça a atteint ces dernières années cent pour cent. Après, les formations IT, ça oscille entre quatre-vingt et cent pour cent.
Ça dépend un peu des profils et des années. Donc ça, je veux dire, ce qui nous tient surtout à cœur, c'est que les personnes qui viennent ici atteignent leur objectif.
Et nous, notre objectif, c'est de mettre tout le monde à l'embauche dans un emploi de qualité. Donc, ce qu'on peut nous souhaiter, c'est d'améliorer ça
et puis de continuer à aider les femmes à s'insérer dans des secteurs qui ne sont pas habituels pour elles et puis de faire en sorte qu'elles deviennent des pionnières pour les autres.
Parce que sensibiliser, c'est une chose, mais former les femmes et puis qu'elles s'installent dans le secteur et puis qu'elles en parlent à leurs filles, à leurs nièces, à leurs voisines, ça, c'est pour moi plus solide.
Donc, je pense qu'il faut vraiment faire des actions positives, qu'on appelle de discrimination positive, même si c'est contradictoire les deux termes, pour qu'il y ait plus de femmes dans le secteur et puis que
voilà, qu'elles tracent la route pour les autres et qu'elles fassent changer les mentalités aussi à l'intérieur des entreprises.
Mais s'élargir pour s'élargir, je pense pas, parce que je crois que garder la taille qu'on a, ça nous permet de faire un travail qui s'apparente au travail de l'artisan. Et je trouve
plus intéressant de faire bien ce qu'on fait puis de servir de modèle éventuellement, par exemple comme on est en train de faire avec Bruxelles Formation, c'est-à-dire on reproduit un peu le même schéma pour entrer dans d'autres métiers.
J'ai peur que s'élargir, ça devienne après une usine et—
Qu'on perde en efficacité.
Qu'on perde en efficacité, voilà. Donc, et puis après, il y a le plaisir de travailler de notre équipe qui est important aussi.
On est trente salariés. C'est vrai qu'on travaille avec une cinquantaine de formateurs freelances aussi. Et voilà, le travail reste agréable pour tout le monde avec cette dimension.
Et si on s'agrandit, je pense qu'on tombe sur d'autres réalités. Voilà donc...
On vous souhaite alors de continuer sur cette lancée et que tout se passe bien encore pour les années à venir.
Laure Lemaire, merci.
Merci beaucoup.
Merci beaucoup pour cet entretien. Et au revoir.
Au revoir.
Sans transition, on passe directement à mon interview avec Isabelle Collet. Isabelle Collet, c'est la référence pour ce qui est des questions des femmes en informatique en francophonie.
Elle est maîtresse en recherche en sciences de l'éducation à l'Université de Genève et ça fait des décennies qu'elle se penche sur ces questions.
Dès qu'on fait une recherche sur le sujet, on tombe sur des dizaines d'articles et de papiers qu'elle a publiés au cours des années.
Elle m'a fait l'honneur de s'entretenir avec moi pendant une demi-heure. Let's go ! Et bonjour à tous. Aujourd'hui, nous recevons Isabelle Collet.
Isabelle Collet, qui est maîtresse en enseignement à l'Université de Genève. Isabelle Collet, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter pour ceux qui ne vous connaissent pas ?
Alors, je suis informaticienne de formation initiale, informaticienne scientifique, traitement d'images numériques, ce genre de choses.
Et ça remonte à quelque temps, vu que j'ai été diplômée dans les années nonante. Et ayant été diplômée à peu près au seul moment où il y a eu une crise de l'informatique, je n'ai pas trouvé de travail à ce moment-là.
D'autant plus, et c'est pas innocent pour la suite de ce que j'ai fait, d'autant plus que j'étais une jeune femme mariée et donc suspectée par mes employeurs de vouloir produire de grandes quantités d'enfants.
Mh. Mh.
Je me suis reconvertie dans la formation, je suis allée faire des études en sciences de l'éducation et—
D'accord.
...ça m'a plu. Donc j'ai passé une thèse en sciences de l'éducation sur la question du genre en informatique. Et je suis maintenant à l'Université de Genève en sciences de l'éducation.
Et donc c'est quoi ? C'est suite à,
voilà, le fait de regarder l'auditoire dans lequel vous vous trouviez
et voir finalement assez peu de femmes dans le secteur de l'informatique qui— est-ce que ça vous a guidée pour vous pencher sur ces questions de genre dans l'éducation ?
Alors pas du tout en fait, parce que, premièrement, j'avais pas remarqué qu'on était peu de filles.
Ah bon.
Pas très observatrice. Mais il faut reconnaître qu'à cette époque-là, on était quand même un quart, donc c'était moins—
D'accord, oui.
...moins visible.
Aujourd'hui, aujourd'hui, ce serait presque un objectif.
Bah voilà, c'est ça. Aujourd'hui, si on avait un quart, ce serait complètement extraordinaire quoi.
Donc c'était moins criant que maintenant, mais y avait aussi le fait que j'avais toujours été environnée essentiellement de garçons dans mes études scientifiques, dans mes loisirs.
Donc ça me semblait pas très différent. La première fois que j'ai mis mes pieds dans un amphithéâtre de sciences de l'éducation, je me suis dit : « Ouh là là, mais 75 %, 80 % de filles, j'vais jamais y arriver quoi ».
Donc c'est vraiment pas ça qui m'a—
Mmm-hmm.
...qui m'a posé souci, mais ça a été plutôt de réaliser que, au niveau de l'entreprise, c'était jamais moi qui étais employée sur un poste stabilisé.
C'est pas à moi qu'on pensait pour encadrer, pour faire carrière. Bref, j'aurais eu un travail intéressant à ce moment-là en informatique, je serais probablement devenue une informaticienne très heureuse.
Alors à la place, je suis devenue une sociologue très heureuse, mais ce n'est pas moi qui ai eu un dégoût ou un désintérêt pour l'informatique.
Uh-huh. Alors on va juste directement se plonger au cœur du sujet. Vous disiez que les ratios avaient évolué au fil du temps.
Les femmes étaient plutôt bien représentées dans l'après-guerre, dans le secteur, et vous disiez 25 % dans les années 90.
Qu'est-ce qui a changé finalement ? Qu'est-ce qui a causé ces changements ?
Alors y a deux facteurs qui ont fonctionné ensemble et malheureusement dans le même sens. Le premier facteur, c'est que quand l'informatique est arrivée, on va dire dans les années 60, 70, évidemment personne ne savait vraiment ce que c'était.
Mmm-hmm.
Les premiers— outre l'armée, les premiers lieux de travail à être équipés en informatique, ça a été les grosses administrations et les banques, par exemple.
Donc quand on était une femme scientifique, ça permettait de travailler dans le secteur tertiaire. Somme toute, c'était pas tellement contre-stéréotypé pour les femmes.
Et puis, y avait pas de prestige dans ces métiers-là. On savait pas très bien où ils allaient mener. Le prestige était toujours en science, par exemple hein, dans les maths pures, dans la physique, etc.
Donc y avait des places pour des femmes qui faisaient des études qu'on appelait calcul numérique, et qui trouvaient de l'emploi scientifique.
Donc ça, c'est une première chose. Et puis, il y a eu de plus en plus des discours qui sont montés sur l'informatique, c'est l'avenir.
Le pays doit entrer de plain-pied dans l'ère de l'informatique pour rester dans la course sur haut niveau industriel mondial, etc.
Et c'est devenu, alors c'est des discours, mais proches de l'incantation hein, c'était vraiment très fort. Et donc on est passé à l'idée que l'informatique, c'était l'emploi assuré, la carrière assurée et un bon salaire.
Et donc, encore plus à cette époque-là que maintenant, même si évidemment, c'est toujours un peu vrai, c'est les garçons que l'on dirige vers l'emploi assuré, vers le bon salaire et vers la carrière.
Donc y a eu un engouffrement massif de jeunes hommes dont les parents, l'école, les discours institutionnels les ont poussés massivement et incités massivement à aller en informatique, qui a pris de plus en plus de prestige.
Donc ça, c'est le premier phénomène. Et simultanément, y avait un deuxième phénomène qui est l'arrivée du micro-ordinateur.
Chaque fois qu'un nouvel appareil technologique arrive, ce sont les garçons qui sont équipés les premiers, que ce soit une console de jeu, un walkman, la télé dans la chambre, ça, c'est toujours vérifié.
Alors pas tous les garçons hein, parce que ça coûte cher, évidemment. Ce sont les garçons de milieux socioprofessionnels favorisés ou les garçons vraiment passionnés qui ont réussi à convaincre tout leur entourage de leur payer un ordinateur.
Parce que quand même, dans les années 80, ouais 80, 90, 90 disons, ça faisait pas grand-chose hein, l'ordinateur personnel.
Mais bon. Donc les garçons sont équipés les premiers et autour de ces ordinateurs se créent des micro-sociétés de garçons.
Je dis micro-société parce que c'était pas une majorité de garçons qui les avaient. Très investis dans le rapport à la machine, ceux qu'on appellerait aujourd'hui les geeks ou les nerds, même si à l'époque, le terme, on le connaissait pas.
En plus, à une époque où ils sont adolescents, c'est-à-dire où le groupe de filles fait peur et qu'ils se replient autour de leurs activités sur l'ordinateur, taper des programmes, programmer des jeux, etc., etc.
Une représentation nouvelle de l'informatique apparaît, d'autant plus qu'y avait pas de représentation au préalable. L'informatique, ce serait faire comme ces jeunes garçons dans leur rapport passionné avec la machine.
Ce serait le monde de l'informatique, ce serait la version adulte de ces jeunes hommes. Alors ça tente pas tous les garçons, évidemment.
Ça tente pas non plus toutes les filles, d'autant plus que pour entrer dans cet univers-là, pour faire partie de ces groupes, c'est beaucoup plus difficile quand on est une fille, on est suspectée d'incompétence.
Et puis en plus, les relations adolescentes, c'est pas ce qu'il y a de plus facile pour la mixité. Et donc on se crée une représentation erronée, mais tout de même solide, de ce que seraient les métiers de l'informatique.
Et quand je dis on, c'est à la fois les jeunes, les parents, le système de l'orientation, les enseignants, etc. Alors, vous avez les deux phénomènes qui se combinent en même temps.
Un métier qui prend de la valeur à la fois symboliquement, mais aussi en termes de carrière, de salaire, etc. Donc on incite fortement les garçons à y aller.
D'autre part, des sollicitations à pratiquer l'informatique plutôt dirigées envers les garçons parce que c'est technique et des micro-sociétés de garçons qui se construisent autour des ordinateurs.
On a une représentation de l'ordinateur qui serait ce qu'on fait quand on est un geek ou un nerd, même si les termes pour le coup sont anachroniques, qui évidemment a tendance à écarter les filles de ces disciplines.
Vous parlez de micro-société de garçons, vous parlez de finalement ces communautés assez adolescentes où les filles ne sont pas les bienvenues.
Ça fait écho un petit peu à ce qu'on voit dans la Silicon Valley avec un certain sexisme dans l'industrie.
On a vu il y a un an, un manifeste d'un employé de Google qui expliquait que les femmes n'avaient pas leur place à la Silicon Valley.
Est-ce que l'industrie de la tech et de l'informatique est plus sexiste que les autres ?
Alors pas plus.
Si on se préoccupe de la part des femmes dans certains secteurs, y a des secteurs, par exemple le secteur de la culture,
et surtout au niveau où on dirige, préside aux destinées, décide des subventions, dirige des théâtres, etc., est plus sexiste que l'informatique.
Donc, il est moins stratégique, il est moins visible, mais c'est pas— 'fin, faut pas qu'on pense que c'est le secteur le pire et le plus fermé.
Néanmoins, effectivement, comme c'est un secteur dans lequel y a du pouvoir, les personnes qui ont ce pouvoir ont plutôt envie de le garder et ont plutôt envie— c'est un milieu comme d'autres hein, qui marche beaucoup par cooptation.
On se rencontre, on travaille ensemble, on s'apprécie, on se coopte, on s'aide, on fait des réseaux. Le système par cooptation, c'est ce qu'il y a de plus efficace pour maintenir en l'état les populations.
C'est-à-dire, on se coopte dans l'entre-soi, même si on n'en a pas conscience.
Mh. Quand je regardais mon propre auditoire de sciences informatiques, je voyais effectivement, comme vous dites, des geeks, des nerds, des gens qui avaient vraiment ça dans le sang,
qui étaient arrivés là par une filière type, ben, la passion pour le jeu vidéo, pour Linux, pour les sujets geeks. Finalement,
c'est le jeu vidéo et la culture geek mainstream était une porte d'entrée pour ces jeunes pour arriver aux études d'informatique qui n'étaient finalement pas vraiment
qui ne ciblaient pas vraiment les jeunes filles.
Comment est-ce qu'on fait pour sortir de ces stéréotypes ? Comment est-ce qu'on fait pour ouvrir une nouvelle porte d'entrée et ramener des femmes dans le secteur de l'informatique ?
Alors, premièrement, il faut pas se tromper de bouc émissaire. Disons, pas choisir les geeks comme bouc émissaire parce que ça déresponsabilise les institutions de leur propre influence en la matière.
Et puis c'est pas la faute aux geeks s'y a pas de filles. C'est-à-dire que premièrement, dans les études d'informatique, on n'apprend pas à être des hackers et on n'apprend pas à être geek.
C'est-à-dire la représentation qu'on peut s'en faire n'est pas réellement— si vous faites des études d'ingénieur en informatique, vous allez pas apprendre à faire du jeu vidéo, vous allez pas apprendre à être un geek.
Mh.
Ça, c'est une première chose. La deuxième chose, c'est que la culture geek, intrinsèquement, elle a rien de sexiste.
C'est-à-dire que dans la culture geek, vous avez peut-être des grands barbares musclés qui se battent
avec des grosses épées, ce qui en soi d'ailleurs est pas forcément désagréable pour les filles, mais vous avez aussi les animations japonaises de Hayao Miyazaki qui n'ont absolument rien de super viril, c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire.
Donc c'est pas une culture qui en soi serait intrinsèquement hostile aux filles. Simplement, en termes de socialisation, c'est vrai que c'est des univers qui sont davantage proposés, cooptés, échangés entre garçons.
Mais de toute façon, le problème, il est pas là. Le problème, c'est les écoles,
et je parle là de l'enseignement supérieur d'abord,
les écoles, c'est à elles de faire les efforts nécessaires, mais des vrais efforts, pas simplement de l'affichage,
pour inciter une population plus variée, et donc plus variée, ça voudra dire nécessairement plus de filles, à venir dans les filières.
C'est-à-dire— alors, des moyens, il en existe, des très, on va dire, très incisifs et puis des moyens qui sont un peu plus en douceur.
Y a trois étapes hein, de toute façon, si on veut réussir à intégrer une population minoritaire, voire très très très minoritaire.
La première, c'est qu'il faut l'intéresser. La deuxième, c'est qu'il faut être en capacité de la recruter. Et la troisième étape, c'est qu'une fois qu'elle soit recrutée, que cette population se sente bien pour qu'elle reste jusqu'au bout.
Si on ne coordonne pas ces trois étapes, ça va pas fonctionner, évidemment. Donc ça veut dire que c'est des actions sur le long terme.
'Fin, en tout cas qui se pensent sur le long terme et qui nécessitent un effort coordonné sur du long terme. Alors, intéresser.
Intéresser, il faut aller chercher la population intéressée là où elle se trouve, c'est-à-dire quand on est une école supérieure, aller les chercher à la fin de l'enseignement secondaire
et donner à ce moment-là envie, attirer, donner envie de venir faire des études.
Alors comment donner envie ? Présenter ce qu'on fait, envoyer des étudiants et des étudiantes faire des démonstrations, former les enseignants
et les enseignantes, en particulier de sciences, pour qu'ils fassent une présentation de la discipline de manière plus mixte.
Et évidemment, dans l'idéal, en ce qui concerne l'informatique, si on pouvait toucher du doigt ce que c'était que la programmation, et je parle pas de programmer des calculatrices pour pouvoir faire des courbes en maths.
Si on avait l'occasion de toucher du doigt
ce qu'est la programmation quand on est dans le secondaire, on pourrait envisager de se projeter dans des études de programmation qui inclut la programmation, même si l'informatique, c'est pas que de la programmation, dans le supérieur.
Mh, mh, mh.
On a un élève—
Oui. Donc, on pourrait alors utiliser l'école comme un égalisateur universel pour vraiment mettre tout le monde au même niveau et proposer l'informatique à ceux qui n'y étaient pas vraiment confrontés avant.
Contrairement à la situation actuelle où c'est seulement les garçons qui ont l'occasion de goûter un peu ça—
Parce que quand on essaie de se projeter : qu'est-ce que je veux faire quand je serai dans l'enseignement supérieur ? On a tendance à reproduire.
Je suis bon en physique, je ferai de la physique. Je suis bonne en maths, je ferai des maths. Bah l'informatique, on sait pas, on n'a pas essayé quoi.
Donc ce serait déjà un pied dans la porte. Mais de toute façon, ces écoles d'informatique, a priori, elles vont avoir trois ans, cinq ans pour former les gens en informatique.
On n'a pas besoin d'avoir des,
des compétences préalables. On va avoir tout le temps de le faire.
C'est-à-dire, ces écoles ont tout intérêt pour intéresser la population à signaler qu'on vous recrute sur des critères qui n'ont rien à voir, 'fin, qui peuvent n'avoir rien à voir avec la technique, mais qui feront partie de ce qu'on attend d'un bon
ou d'une bonne professionnelle de l'informatique.
Comme s'impliquer dans sa communauté, être bénévole, avoir des capacités d'organisation, des compétences en langues, etc., etc.
On sait que en France, depuis— alors,
vous êtes Suisse, je suis Belge, mais il me semble avoir entendu que depuis peu, il y avait de l'informatique au sein du secondaire dans l'enseignement obligatoire en France.
Ça commence.
Oui, ça commence tout doucement. Est-ce que vous pensez que, bah d'ici une dizaine d'années, on va ressentir justement cet effet, avoir un peu plus de mixité grâce à ça ?
Tout dépend comment les— 'fin, à quel point l'expérience va être menée, menée sérieusement et jusqu'où. C'est-à-dire que pour l'instant, y a de l'informatique, pas partout.
Y a des logiques de géographie très importantes, c'est-à-dire selon l'établissement dans lequel vous êtes, vous en avez ou vous en avez pas.
C'est une option. Donc à partir du moment où on a une option, les différences des sexes réapparaissent et les groupes se répartissent.
Ah oui, forcément. Ça peut pas être une option.
Voilà. Et en plus— alors, c'est destiné à devenir obligatoire, au collège, au secondaire un. Là, tout le monde passera par là.
Cela peut être, là, on verra des transformations. Mais pour l'instant, au secondaire deux, c'est une option. Et l'autre problème, c'est que souvent, qui fait cette option ?
Le prof de maths. Et donc on y va en gros si on aime bien ou si on n'aime pas le prof de maths ou si on se sent à l'aise ou pas.
C'est ça.
Donc on a une combo maths info qui va probablement pas attirer des... Non pas que les filles sont pas bonnes en maths hein, mais elles ont pas particulièrement confiance en elles dans ce domaine. Et en plus—
C'est ça. Elles s'identifient pas comme étant les plus compétentes en maths.
Et en plus de la part de profs qui ne sont pas formés à cette spécificité qui est qu'on a besoin de produire de la mixité parce que la discipline elle-même n'envoie pas ce signal.
Si les profs— alors y a des établissements où les profs ont pris conscience de ça, se sont formés et envoient des messages très clairs et rame d'ailleurs, mais enfin ils y arrivent, pour avoir un peu plus de mixité dans leur filière.
Mais si on touche à rien, eh ben on va reproduire le même modèle. Alors par contre, l'informatique qui arrive au collège, ça, c'est intéressant parce que tout le monde va en faire.
Donc tout le monde va toucher du doigt.
Là, j'espère vraiment que le programme qui va être fait ne sera pas fait que par les profs de maths ou en tout cas sera fait par des personnes qui auront préalablement une formation sur les questions genre
ou en tout cas sur ces enjeux pour qu'on reproduise pas un schéma où on voit ce qu'il donne quoi.
Mh.
C'est intéressant. Dans un de vos papiers, vous
vous expliquez que seule une mixité réfléchie et travaillant en classe offrant un cadre contrôlé et sécurisant
peut autoriser des comportements moins normés, ouvrir le débat entre garçons et filles et permettre de recréer le lien d'empathie nécessaire pour aller à la rencontre de l'autre.
Qu'est-ce que c'est finalement cette mixité réfléchie ? Ce que vous expliquez comme quoi il faut former les enseignants aux questions de mixité, aux questions de genre.
Qu'est-ce que ça donne concrètement, un professeur qui est formé à ces questions ?
Alors la première chose, l'étape zéro, c'est que l'enseignant ou l'enseignante arrête de penser que le seul fait de mettre des élèves filles et garçons ensemble produit de la mixité.
Ça, c'est pas vrai. En fait, la mixité à l'école, on l'a encore jamais essayée. On a produit de la juxtaposition des sexes.
Par contre, il suffit de regarder une classe pour comprendre que c'est de la juxtaposition.
C'est-à-dire, les élèves, alors éventuellement, ils se chahutent, ils se séduisent, ils plaisantent, ils se défient, ils s'insultent, mais ils travaillent pas ensemble.
Et d'ailleurs, ils ne le souhaitent pas.
Mh, mh.
C'est-à-dire quand vous les mettez en groupe de travail, c'est comme la vinaigrette hein, l'huile et le vinaigre se reséparent si on mélange.
Ouais, tout à fait. Tout à fait.
Donc la première chose, c'est prendre conscience de ça et se dire que c'est pas une fatalité et que c'est pas nécessairement désirable.
Alors, je comprends les enseignants qui disent à cet âge-là, c'est-à-dire quand on est adolescent, on n'a pas forcément envie de travailler avec l'autre sexe, ce qui est vrai.
Et autant les mettre dans des bonnes conditions de travail et leur permettre de travailler avec des personnes qu'ils apprécient.
Dans la vraie vie, dans le monde professionnel, on travaille avec des gens avec lesquels on n'a pas envie de travailler.
Et ça veut pas dire qu'on va faire du mauvais travail avec eux. Et il faut faire avec. L'école, c'est aussi, c'est ce que disait l'éducation nouvelle, c'est un laboratoire de la vie.
On apprend à travailler ensemble, y compris avec des gens qui sont pas nos amis et on constate que c'est pas grave et on constate qu'on fait pas forcément du mauvais travail.
Seulement, pour entrer dans cette logique-là, il faut que les enseignants,
dès le début d'année, se donnent la peine de mélanger, c'est-à-dire d'instaurer des pratiques où on va travailler ensemble dans des groupes qui vont varier garçons et filles.
Faut aussi regarder comment les groupes travaillent. C'est-à-dire, y a des phénomènes qui se mettent en place très vite, c'est-à-dire les filles qui disent : « C'est moi qui écris tout, comme ça, ce sera propre et bien fait.
» Alors au fait, effectivement—
Ça, oui, j'ai déjà vu, oui.
Elles ont une espèce de leadership sur le groupe hein, pour le coup, mais c'est quand même elles qui se tapent le travail et ça les place déjà en service d'un groupe, avec les garçons qui pensent et elles qui rendent compte.
Donc il faut faire tourner les rôles au sein des groupes alors même que les élèves, ni les garçons ni les filles le souhaitent hein.
Les garçons qui disent : « C'est drôlement bien d'être dans un groupe de filles parce qu'elles sont sérieuses et on bosse mieux.
Les filles en assistantes pédagogiques des garçons. Ça fait pas du bien. Alors, on se plaint indéfiniment de l'immaturité des garçons quand ils sont ados.
Ce genre de situation ne permet pas de sortir de ces discours d'immaturité.
Donc ça, c'est une première posture de la part des enseignants de vérifier comment les élèves, 'fin, de mettre en sorte les bonnes conditions pour que les élèves travaillent ensemble et de manière égalitaire.
Et puis, dans la posture, dans les gestes au quotidien de la classe, il y a beaucoup de facteurs à prendre en compte, comme par exemple regarder ses contenus d'enseignement.
Si on fait aveuglément confiance au livre de classe, y a de bonnes chances qu'on diffuse du stéréotype à longueur de temps.
Donc regarder ses contenus d'enseignement,
se préoccuper de comment la parole est distribuée dans la classe. En gros, si on laisse faire
lors d'un cours dialogué, c'est-à-dire un cours où l'enseignant pose des questions aux élèves, les élèves répondent et c'est ce qui fait avancer le cours, la répartition du temps de parole au secondaire, c'est deux tiers, un tiers.
Deux tiers de prise de parole par les garçons, un tiers pour les filles. Pas tous les garçons. En général, c'est un petit groupe de garçons qui sont dévorants.
Mais le fait est, vous fermez les yeux, vous écoutez la classe, y a deux fois plus de prises de parole de garçons que de filles.
Des filles qui parlent de manière plus courte, qui se font interrompre. Dès qu'elles hésitent, on leur reprend la parole, etc.
Bon ça, c'est des choses aussi que l'enseignant, l'enseignante doit contrôler dans sa classe. Et puis faire attention aux exemples qu'on apporte, à la manière dont on peut varier les différentes formes d'apprentissage.
Moi, je fais un cours là-dessus, il fait 30 heures quoi. Ça s'apprend pas en deux coups de cuillère à pot. C'est une vraie, un vrai apprentissage.
C'est une vraie formation des enseignants et des enseignantes qu'il faut intégrer, à mon sens, dans le quotidien de la classe.
Parce que quand on commence à faire attention à ça, à cette dimension égalité filles garçons, on se met à faire attention à de nombreuses dimensions d'égalité en termes de classe sociale et en termes d'origine ethnique.
C'est-à-dire y a beaucoup de choses qui se mettent à aller avec. Et à la fin, on produit un enseignement plus égalitaire.
Mmm-mmh. Et de nos jours, ce n'est pas le cas ? Les professeurs ne sont pas formés à ces questions ?
Alors tout dépend où ils habitent. S'ils habitent Genève, oui. Parce que—
D'accord
...le canton de Genève a rendu ces cours obligatoires et évalués tant pour les enseignants de primaire et du secondaire, dans des proportions variées, mais en tout cas, ça existe.
En France, bah, ça dépend dans quelle école, dans quelle SP vous êtes formé. Et en Belgique, c'est un peu ça aussi, c'est-à-dire que y a un cours pour les enseignants qui traite de diversité,
dont le programme, pour l'instant, est laissé au bon vouloir de la personne qui donne ce cours, une personne qui n'est pas nécessairement formée elle-même spécifiquement aux questions d'égalité entre les sexes.
Donc vous pouvez faire des choses très très bien selon où vous êtes et des choses qui ne parleront peut-être exclusivement que de diversité, de handicap ou je sais pas, voilà.
Mmm-mmh. Et du côté du canton de Genève, est-ce qu'on observe, en conséquence de ce cours, est-ce qu'on observe des améliorations, des changements ?
Alors, on observe des changements dans les pratiques, ce qui ne suffit pas pour avoir des changements dans les orientations. C'est-à-dire—
D'accord
...dans les pratiques, on a des enseignants et des enseignantes qui disent que la question de l'égalité des sexes est une question vive de l'éducation.
Alors que dans les cantons voisins, non. Non pas que l'égalité soit obtenue dans les cantons voisins, c'est que simplement, à Genève, on pense encore que c'est un sujet.
Les établissements scolaires font— 'fin beaucoup d'établissements scolaires, du primaire en particulier, mais du secondaire également, ont des activités, des semaines égalité ou des choses de ce genre.
Les établissements du secondaire font beaucoup de choses sur la lutte contre l'homophobie. Mais y a dans le canton, on va dire, une culture de l'égalité qui fait que les enseignants, les enseignantes peuvent s'emparer des sujets.
Et c'est un sujet qui existe. Bon, après, il faut que l'orientation suive. Et c'est là le problème. C'est-à-dire qu'actuellement,
dans ce qu'on appelle les écoles d'apprentissage, c'est-à-dire qui vous mèneront aux filières professionnelles et éventuellement à l'enseignement supérieur professionnel, cette culture de l'égalité, on va dire, elle existe pas quoi.
Très peu. Et donc aujourd'hui, en termes d'orientation, on a un problème. C'est-à-dire, il suffit pas de dire : « Les métiers n'ont pas de sexe.
» Après, il faut le prouver quoi. Et c'est là que ça cloche.
Et je ne pense pas qu'il suffise de former les enseignants et qu'il suffise d'informer les élèves si le reste de la chaîne de l'orientation ne suit pas et si les écoles ne suivent pas en prenant des décisions
fortes et énergiques, ça suffira pas à changer les choses.
Mmm-mmh. On va revenir un instant au sujet de l'informatique. J'ai eu l'occasion d'interviewer Laure Lemaire, la directrice de Interface3.
Et en discutant avec elle, c'était très intéressant de voir que finalement, les élèves de Interface3 qui souhaitaient se former aux questions d'informatique
allaient là-bas non pas pour des questions de, comme on disait, bah, geek, nerd, j'ai ça dans le sang, c'est ma passion, mais plutôt pour des raisons très pragmatiques, très pratiques.
Ils sont belges. Ce sont des métiers qui ramènent de l'argent, ce sont des métiers qui amènent une certaine stabilité, un certain, oui, un CDI.
Et donc voilà. Et donc on voit toutes ces jeunes filles, y en a, j'crois, une bonne cinquantaine, ce qui est infiniment plus que ce qu'on voit dans le supérieur en Belgique.
Mais c'était très intéressant de voir que finalement, ces questions-là, ces questions pratiques ramenaient infiniment plus de filles que, bah, les questions, 'fin l'aspect identitaire, l'aspect geek, nerd et tout ça.
Je vais faire un raccourci et vous allez me dire si vous pensez que je dis une énorme bêtise, mais il se trouve que la Belgique est le pays d'Europe où le patrimoine individuel est le plus élevé et
Elle est troisième dans le monde derrière la Suisse et Dubaï.
Donc il semble qu'en Belgique et en Suisse, on soit particulièrement aisés, particulièrement stables d'un point de vue financier.
Est-ce que simplement la raison qui fait qu'on est les plus mauvais élèves en termes de participation des femmes aux questions,
aux filières informatiques,
est-ce que simplement ce ne serait pas en partie parce qu'on vit dans une société où on est relativement aisés financièrement et que donc on a
moins de femmes qui doivent se tourner vers l'informatique pour des raisons pratiques, des raisons financières ?
Est-ce que ce serait pas une partie de la réponse ?
Il y a un article qui est sorti récemment, en gros sur ce thème-là, en disant que y avait moins de femmes— dans les pays les plus favorisés, y avait moins de femmes dans les sciences que dans les pays les plus défavorisés.
Et donc qui irait dans cette direction-là, c'est-à-dire qu'elles ont pas besoin, donc elles vont vers ce qui les tente naturellement.
Alors là, on voit la pente savonneuse de la naturalisation des compétences hein—
Disons, naturellement dans des sociétés genrées.
Oui oui, c'est ça, voilà, on est bien d'accord. En fait, par exemple, si on regarde,
la part des femmes dans l'enseignement supérieur en Suisse, enfin dans le monde, je veux dire, on s'aperçoit que la Suisse et le Japon sont très proches.
Sont beaucoup plus proches que la Suisse et ses pays voisins, ce qui peut paraître étonnant. Là, c'est plutôt une question de tradition, c'est-à-dire qu'en Suisse, en particulier en Suisse alémanique,
s'il y a un bon salaire, le mieux, c'est de garder les enfants à la maison, sous-entendu les femmes.
Et pendant très longtemps, l'école, un peu sur le modèle allemand, n'aidait pas du tout à permettre de travailler quand on avait de jeunes enfants.
Quand on regarde par exemple le nombre de femmes très important qu'il peut y avoir dans les études d'informatique ou de physique en Iran ou en Palestine, bon c'est pour d'autres raisons.
C'est-à-dire qu'en Palestine, les garçons vont plutôt dans les filières militaires, armées, de combat politique. En Iran, elles sont en informatique, mais de toute façon, beaucoup d'entre elles ne pourront pas travailler, etc., etc.
Donc vous voyez, y a des logiques assez variées. Pour la Belgique, pour le coup, je peux pas vous dire à quel point il peut y avoir une culture industrielle.
Vous voyez, par exemple, le Luxembourg, qui a aussi des chiffres en ingénierie qui sont absolument microscopiques. Le Luxembourg est passé un peu directement d'une culture minière à une culture bancaire tout aussi patriarcale.
Alors OK, financièrement, ça va, donc on peut s'en accommoder, mais je pense pas que ce soit la cause première, vous voyez ?
C'est-à-dire effectivement, on peut s'en accommoder. Y a pas une question de survie. Mais voilà. Mais partie—
Donc vous pensez que l'histoire du pays, l'histoire de la culture, donc l'aspect industriel, l'aspect traditionnel que vous évoquiez serait déjà plus une cause.
Mais est-ce que finalement, l'aspect financier qu'on évoque ici ne participe pas du tout ? Est-ce que ce ne serait pas quelque chose qui empêche ?
C'est un moteur, c'est un moteur second. C'est-à-dire quand il faut trouver— si Interface3 formait beaucoup de femmes, alors moi, j'y ai travaillé il y a maintenant une dizaine d'années, où j'étais consultante.
Y avait énormément de femmes migrantes en reprise d'études. On leur disait : « Là, y a du boulot. Eh ben OK, pourquoi pas l'informatique ?
» Donc c'est un moteur hein. Ce que je trouve navrant, c'est qu'on soit dans la situation de dire : « OK, la nécessité me permettra de passer outre l'appréhension que je pourrais avoir pour venir en informatique.
» Sur cette histoire de,
« Je l'ai dans le sang, je suis née pour ça », plus les garçons et les filles qui vont plus pour des raisons pragmatiques, c'est un distinguo qu'on trouve très très souvent,
quand on interviewe garçons et filles sur l'informatique.
Bon, ce qui est vraiment intéressant là-dessus et qui déconstruit un peu cette représentation, alors, c'est que premièrement,
les geeks sont une fraction visible et sympathique de la discipline, mais pas la majorité des personnes qui travaillent en informatique.
C'est une petite fraction qui devient représentative, mais qui en fait n'est pas représentative de monsieur, madame Tout-le-Monde, plutôt monsieur et monsieur Tout-le-Monde, qui travaillent en informatique.
Deuxièmement— mais ils sont réputés pour être brillants et extrêmement compétents. C'est pour ça qu'on les met en avant.
Ils viennent avec une pop culture qui est également tout à fait sympathique.
Mais l'université Carnegie Mellon, qui a fait d'énormes efforts pour intégrer plus de femmes en informatique, suffisamment d'efforts pour avoir environ entre 30 et 40 % de manière stable, bon c'est quand même plutôt pas mal hein,
sont revenus sur ce distinguo, les garçons qui programment pour l'amour de l'art, les filles qui travaillent parce que ça sert à quelque chose.
Une fois qu'ils ont fait tous leurs efforts d'intégration dont je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure, intéresser, recruter, socialiser, ce distinguo n'existe plus.
C'est-à-dire, les filles comme les garçons disent qu'ils sont là pour l'amour de l'art et parce que ça sert à quelque chose.
C'est difficile pour une fille, sauf si elle assume réellement son côté geek avec toute la panoplie qui va avec, de dire : « Je suis là pour l'amour de l'art.
» Parce que ça amène des conséquences en termes de moins séduisante, moins féminine, moins tout un tas de choses. On peut l'assumer hein.
Moi, quand j'étais en études d'informatique, le terme existait pas, mais j'étais une geek et j'étais très heureuse comme ça.
C'est pas des représentations que beaucoup de filles peuvent se permettre si elles veulent rester dans une certaine représentation de ce qu'est une fille séduisante, ce qu'est une vraie fille.
Si cette représentation tombait, je pense qu'on découvrirait plus de geekettes.
D'accord. Et donc l'institut que vous citez, Carnegie Mellon, est-ce qu'ils sont arrivés à des chiffres intéressants en termes de ratio hommes/femmes ?
Bah je vous dis 30 à 40 % de manière stable.
D'accord. Oui, effectivement, c'est énorme.
Donc on peut estimer que c'est plutôt pas mal hein.
Ouais, tout à fait.
D'ailleurs, ça m'a rassurée de découvrir ça parce que je me demandais si on allait vraiment y arriver. Bon, ben il y a des gens qui peuvent quoi.
Eux, ils y arrivent. NTNU en Norvège, à Trondheim, pareil, 30 à 40 %. On peut le faire. Une volonté politique forte de l'école, on peut le faire.
Oui, mais justement, une volonté politique forte de l'école, on voit que finalement, l'institut qui est l'enseignement obligatoire, finalement assez statique, assez inerte, évolue assez peu finalement sur les dernières 30 années.
Et en Belgique, ce qu'on observe, c'est finalement de plus en plus
d'acteurs tertiaires, indépendants du ministère de l'Enseignement, qui vont former à l'informatique et à toutes ces questions, indépendamment, 'fin à l'extérieur de l'enseignement obligatoire.
Est-ce que ce n'est pas finalement vers ça qu'on se dirige, face à un enseignement inerte qui ne s'améliore pas pour les questions, ben de,
de genre, de mixité, voilà, d'améliorer l'image de l'informatique comme le ferait Carnegie Mellon ?
Ben alors, ces écoles, donc Trondheim, NTNU ou Carnegie Mellon, ont fait avec. C'est-à-dire, ils sont l'enseignement supérieur.
Le secondaire, ils ont pas pris direct dessus. Peu importe, on va pas s'y résigner. Ils ont fait avec un enseignement secondaire qui est tel qu'il est.
Néanmoins, je suis d'accord avec vous, ça veut pas dire qu'on a— alors, je dis ça parce que ça veut dire qu'on doit pas se résigner.
C'est-à-dire souvent, on attend, ça se renvoyait la balle. « Ah, mais nous, on est l'enseignement supérieur, tout le problème vient du secondaire.
» Le secondaire, il dit : « Ouh là là, nous, ils sont déjà tous stéréotypés, tout le problème vient de la primaire » et on se renvoie la balle jusqu'aux familles, finalement.
Bon, c'est jamais perdu, et on peut être un institut de l'enseignement supérieur et faire quelque chose avec la situation telle qu'elle est.
Par ailleurs, oui, effectivement, il faut agir à tous les niveaux. Et je constate également en France qu'un certain nombre
d'activités en parallèle, en périscolaire, se mettent à apparaître ou alors en apprentissage, en école de la seconde chance, en formation a posteriori, se mettent à former des personnes en informatique qui n'ont pas été formées avant.
Alors, y a un certain nombre de domaines comme ça où l'école se décharge sur des associations d'une partie d'enseignement qui sont, à mon avis, de sa responsabilité.
L'égalité des sexes en fait partie d'ailleurs, l'éducation à la sexualité, etc. Malheureusement, l'informatique semble en faire partie aussi.
Je pense qu'on est quand même dans un mouvement, en tout cas en Suisse comme en France, où on discute de réintégrer, je dis réintégrer parce que dans les années 80, c'était un peu plus là, de réintégrer l'informatique dans l'enseignement général.
Après, y a des arbitrages compliqués, y a des questions de sous, c'est-à-dire que la journée de l'élève n'est pas extensible.
Si on rentre l'informatique, qu'est-ce qu'on sort ? Qu'est-ce qu'on accepte de sortir ? Qu'est-ce qu'on va juger important, moins important, plus important ?
Est-ce qu'on va réellement mettre le prix pour former des enseignants compétents dans ces disciplines ? Ou est-ce qu'on va se dire : « Ouah, les profs de maths, ils vont nous brutoler un machin et ça va faire l'affaire.
» ? Est-ce qu'on veut vraiment jouer le jeu ? C'est des histoires d'argent et des histoires de stratégie politique. Ça vient d'en haut.
Est-ce que les directions des systèmes éducatifs vont prendre la mesure de l'enjeu et en particulier de l'enjeu en égalité ?
La question se pose.
Oui, oui. C'est, je crois, le plus gros obstacle au changement. C'est effectivement, ben finalement, le budget, le politique.
Et vaste sujet que nous n'aurons pas le temps d'aborder puisque je dois vous libérer, Isabelle Collet. Merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous.
C'était vraiment très intéressant. Est-ce que—
Je vous remercie de votre invitation.
Est-ce que nos auditeurs peuvent vous suivre quelque part ?
Non.
Pas de réseaux sociaux, pas de Twitter, pas de—
Je n'ai pas le temps, donc je tweete pas. J'ai un site où par contre, on peut trouver un grand nombre de mes articles.
D'accord.
Et parce que comme je suis dans la recherche publique, j'estime que mes articles doivent être publics, donc on peut me lire.
Mais non, à mon grand regret, c'est pas parce que j'aime pas ou que ça m'intéresse pas, mais j'ai pas le temps de tweeter ou de faire quelque chose de vivant qui me permette d'être suivie.
Merci beaucoup Isabelle Collet. Au revoir.
Merci beaucoup, au revoir.
Et voilà, c'est déjà tout pour ce deuxième épisode de Septante Minutes Avec. Pour ceux que ça intéresse, je rappelle que je vais bientôt publier un article sur le sujet des femmes en informatique en Belgique.
Ça s'appellera « Des souris et que des hommes ». Ce sera sur Medium et je publierai le lien sur Twitter dès que ce sera prêt.
Pour me suivre sur Twitter, il y a un lien dans la description. N'oubliez pas de vous abonner au podcast pour ne manquer aucun épisode de Septante Minutes Avec. À très bientôt.